Bill what's it like to have coined the
term that everyone's still uses to this
day like booty calling everyone's still
using it's just fun because that's what
it was meant to be fun like you know
because Robbie will tell you when we
first start doing comedy and stuff we
couldn't it's we had to be so crafty to
say stuff on TV so like
um you know you do NBC you do tonight's
show whatever you could not say nothing
wrong they will not air your [__] so we
always have to be clever on how to
either say the joke or so booty call to
me was just something you could flavor
for fun bubbly you know what I mean so
when I was thinking of I was like I'm
gonna make me a booty call
whoa that I could see that on TV yeah
and you're like officially in the
dictionary yeah yeah and and girls can
say it's not nasty it's like oh like I
think I had a booty call you know and
when I heard women say it I knew it was
it was working yeah because women were
like oh my God I I think I had a booty
call like you know I'm like oh so you
you heard it here yes Bill Bellamy
came up was the guy that came up with
booty call that's insane yeah you coined
it yeah how insane is that it is crazy I
didn't know it would stick like I
remember one day right I'll be honest
with you I was just like wow if I if I
knew you know I would have patented and
did all this trademark [__] but I didn't
know at the time it's like I was just
writing jokes and [__] when I had
trademarked it though like what is it it
would be residual money for everything
Brandon everything yeah because like
Taco Bell did foodie called that oh
wow booty call was a movie there's so
many different things that they're
derivative you [__] up I [__] up and
so so the crazy part was when I was
watching happy birthday
okay
did you know that you missed out I
missed out dude happy birthday Is My Jam
dude that's your jam yeah dude happy
birthday too that's you and the only
word you know that I didn't write is
because of the little space when you say
the guy's name
that's the part you missed yeah well I
mean that's I left that open so that you
can interject Phil or John or whatever
you are you a time that's cool that was
clever on my part very clever yeah yeah
um when I was watching friends and they
and they had it in the script I was just
like I just heard him say it I was like
this is the whitest most popular show
ever and they said oh my God I had a
booty call last night and I was like
what whoa that was crazy so if if you
had trademarked it they would you would
have they give you something for that
every time every time you say it would
they use something different or they're
like oh we don't you can't even fix it
because you can't think of nothing that
sounds better than booty call that's
true because it just says it it's what
it is it's like telephone what is she
gonna say yeah it's telephone it's a
telephone It's like because it's saying
it without saying it's like bam right in
the pocket and then the funny part was
um
it backfired on me too because when I
was single and you know I would have you
know somebody come over whatever and his
chicks be like am I a booty call or is
this like
am I like am I gonna see you again or am
I a booty girl like I always had to like
go through that [__] you know what I'm
saying I'm like whoa
you spent the night you did good like I
tell people what people didn't believe
that you came up with it people know
people especially comedians yeah yeah
comedians know and [__] like that but
people that just got it carted in the in
their culture like caught it off a TV
they're not gonna go backwards and find
it they just gonna know what it is and
say it yeah that's what it is that's
incredible like um
um
what's a trip right so I did this movie
called how to be a player right yeah
how to be a player is mentioned my name
is mentioned on so many hip-hop records
because of that movie whoa I just saw
Nicki Minaj did a song and it was like
what what you trying to tell you what
you trying to tell me you ain't no
player you ain't Bill Bellamy oh
Nikki thank you oh my God so many
different ways they are it is like
how do you know what you're going to do
in the culture like how the hell you
gonna know which thing which joke is
your like Landmark how you know which
movie role is going to be the one that
knocks you into like legendary status
you never know I've never come up with
anything you better hurry up
I mean how come I haven't come what have
I come up with
nothing that's sort of my
corn corn corn
yeah corn yeah but that's not in part of
the [__] culture culture but I'm
thinking what he say what Bill's saying
I've said nothing you know my fear is
like moving forward and like dating you
know after you is that the association
between just Bobby and kalila is very um
strong yeah and like I don't know if
anyone can like compete with that you
guys are like
you guys are interesting